There was,
yeah, yeah, me [music] No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's the perfect pasteurization that makes the most of the
fresh cream
.  Senbei Rice crackers
and chopped rice crackers are spread thinly with sesame oil
and baked to a crisp
.  It's
the root wrapped around the breast meat, and it's the root that's
flavored with seasonings mixed with bread
and Kainokawa.  Refers to rolled and baked
cinnamon.It's a
cooking method that allows you to add texture and color to the ingredients
.
I hurriedly mixed the ingredients with the crew who was planning to wrap them around the chicken
Shitakata is an excellent secret ingredient that deepens the blackness of chicken
.  When
I go to take the main selfie, I get p's croon.
By doing so, the deliciousness that echoes below will rise to the main position